well let's talk about what's happening
here in the united states we got this
from the new york post
facebook removes freedom convoy page of
truckers against vax mandates they say
a protest organized a facebook page
organizing a protest of u.s truckers
against mandates has been removed and
and you know what facebook said
the group's convoy to dc 2022 was
removed wednesday for violating policies
around q anon what remember when julie
kelly was here and she was like wait
until they claim cuanon's there oh yeah
they're doing it two years ago she
nailed it she was ahead of the curve on
that one what so um us truckers want to
do a convoy they want to go i think it's
from like west coast to dc
we're really close to dc we would we
would have people on the ground covering
it if it were to happen and facebook
shuts it down they banned the guy
who uh this is what was reported the guy
who set it up just a regular facebook
profile it banned him too
they really do not want this to keep
happening it is like it's like occupy
wall street but like for real yeah
you know what i mean yeah well
astro turf lefty garbage well in the
beginning uh it represented an idea that
unified the left and the right and
people who just wanted accountability
from the banking system that was truly
controlling our way of lives especially
after the 2008 financial crisis but this
also represents another major time in
our existence where a lot of people are
realizing that they were conned that
they were lied about that they were
screwed over and they want some
accountability they want some justice
they want their lives to have some kind
of normalcy and have a semblance of it
and i think truckers are the backbone of
of many countries including in this
country they're realizing it and
understanding that they have collective
power this idea has caught on in
australia it has caught on in holland it
has caught on in some ways here in the
united states but it's being stifled so
this idea doesn't grow as of course the
big tech corporate monopolies are making
sure that this idea is constrained and
of course doesn't expand to the point
where it has expanded in canada where
they have already
done many actions that have led to a
significant conversation that the
establishment does not want to have
right now this is a crazy year already
man yeah
you know what i want to do you know you
know you know what i'm imagining in my
head as luke's talking i'm just thinking
about
chicago on a warm spring evening
i'm in a nice like second floor
apartment
walk over the couch turn on the tv you
put on a movie where friends are all
there and we order a pizza and some
wings and we're sitting there and we're
talking about nonsense just having a
laugh and
it's the way things used to be back in
the day and now it's just yo it's so
chaotic yeah every everything is
politics everything is is conflict it's
getting crazier there's no moment where
you just turn on a show and try i mean
there are these little moments in there
i was watching batman earlier just
trying to like just get away from
everything but i saw on uh as i browse
read it again there is a subreddit
called non-political twitter because our
culture has pop culture is just politics
at this point it is everything are there
like five tweets there yeah
and they're like i've i found them
finally
yeah probably five individuals just
being like hi the weather's okay
everything's even the weather is
becoming political
especially in texas especially with our
energy and infrastructure policies in
texas so it's the apocalypse crews
they're like ted cruz is tweeting about
cancun again and it's like and every day
is a major news day every day something
significant happens to the point where
if you even tune out for two weeks you
will be totally lost and not
understanding of what's really happening
in our modern society could you imagine
going to jail for like four months
i was about to tell you guys
while i was in there all i had was like
an rss feed to like cnn that's it the
fox news rss
the fox news rss feed just doesn't work
it's just a blank page
and i missed so much like everybody came
out and they're like hey did you hear
about this did you hear about that
and it's it's overwhelming to try to
catch up to it you know i'm trying for
for since january and i know we're going
to get into that a little bit later
since january you know i eat sleep and
breathe like j6 cases i'd listen into
all the court cases take a look at all
the arguments and now just to catch up
it's impossible it's overwhelming like i
get home and i'm like okay i'm going to
read about this and i'm like you know
what
i'm not i'm just going to disconnect and
i'm just going to
relax did you have access to information
while you were in jail just to see in an
rss feed
so basically just not even news yeah
nothing i had three i had three forums
to read the media the news the rss feed
from cnn i'd we'd get the washington
post
and then there's this local dc newspaper
that would it was we i'm sorry it's
weekly uh dc newspaper and two of the
pages two out of the ten pages were
written by louis farrakhan ah what i
have it i have it i'll send you guys a
picture and that was the only way that
you got news
i i i'm imagining this and i'm like
trying to trying to get news in your
circumstance would be akin to like
crawling through the desert starving and
someone comes with a big basket of fruit
and you're like oh thank you and you
bite into it it's wax yeah it's like
it's not even food
that's cnn i'll be honest it was
it was a little refreshing
you know it was a little refreshing to
like
not be
locked in that 23 hour and one gulag but
it was refreshing to where i'm not like
constantly
worried about the state of the country
like i'm in the worst part in the of of
the country and i was only there for a
short time
uh
but if if the only media you could
consume in there is that you know um and
then the education program
what was that like oh dude again we'll
get into that a little later was it like
woke
no super woke it was it was just and i i
i wrote down uh i broke down the entire
curriculum for the education program by
bias
uh by
um biographies
uh and i'll tell you about that a little
bit later but yeah there's a huge huge
bias it's it's it's a machine in there
bro well so this is why facebook nukes
the organizers but here's what i want to
say about that
you know
i'm actually kind of grateful
that our generations elites are some of
the stupidest
mother
effers
you know ever
because if we had like actually
competent elites they'd be manipulating
controlling everything and you wouldn't
even notice but these are like the
grandkids of the you know they've
inherited this world as the elites from
the past generations and they're just
really really dumb it's like the inbred
royalty they're just like
like too stupid to realize what's going
on and so they're like what do we do
they're organizing again quick ban their
profile and they ban it and then ever
now now we're talking about it now ever
it's streisand affecting they didn't
know that was going to happen so my only
thought process is like they can't be
that dumb can they unless unless
it's on purpose they wanted the convoy
to get more attention
so they banned it on purpose that way we
talk about it and it gets bigger but i
can't believe that it's just i don't
think that's smart i think they're
really dumb people yeah i think you're
right i think there's something there's
gymnastics to
to really
get that going
i mean i think there's an effort to try
to conceal everything that's why this
was done on a friday i think there are a
lot of really dumb ass individuals that
are put into positions of power
especially inside of the government but
i also think there is a super
intelligent uh kind of elitist group
that do uh you know arrange a lot of
these zombies into a position that
benefits them greatly at the cost of
everyone else so i i think you know
what's happening right now it's really
hard to quantify in many elements
because things are moving so fast and so
rapidly it's hard to even get a
consensus of exactly what's going on
here but uh it wouldn't surprise me if
these were uncalculated desperate moves
made by desperate individuals who are
who have
a lot of people losing faith in them a
lot of people are saying i don't trust
the government the government lied to me
the government screwed me over the
government locked me down the government
took away my job the government took
away my social life the government took
away my form of existence the government
wants me in a pod eating bugs on vr
virtual reality and i don't want to live
in that kind of life where i have no
privacy i don't own anything and i'm
allegedly going to be happy no i don't
want that
you're saying you don't want to live in
the pot and eat the bugs no what are you
a racist
that's that's the talking points that
we're probably going to be hearing in a
few days
could you would you be allowed to have
an oculus when you were in jail would
they give you one
jesus
jesus no it was a it was an educational
tablet with like
trump man bad
how he's killed democracy
how the uh
i can't say it on the show but uh about
that about vaccines about the election
and things like that uh very very very
log bro yeah yeah literally
it was really hard not to get programmed
it was really really hard not to get
programmed would they ask you to like
repeat what you were reading like now
tell us the things that we i had you
read i should have brought it i have i
have a
in the education program they they gave
me like a a piece of paperwork to do and
it said uh how to identify your
unconscious bias
wow that was that was the entire i know
again i'll send you guys
that's like re-education yeah yeah and
that's the only that's the only media
that you could consume were you alone
were you like in isolation or um
yeah for the most part i was in
isolation for the first three months
then uh the us marshals had come in and
did like that whole press release
um about the conditions being unlivable
and uh i fired the alarms on that i went
to court and then after i went to court
they rolled out the red carpet they they
sent me to like this unit and but i was
only
i was only out of the isolation for
about 10 days before
guess what came by
joe biden omicron
oh and then what omnicron 23 and 1.
again back to iso
when you're talking isolation is that
literally it's you alone in a small room
you alone in a small room for 23 hours a
day uh and towards december they pushed
it even more where they'd only let you
out for 15 minutes a day just to take a
shower and come back in
in you have a like a light bulb one
light bulb or something you have a light
bulb and then yeah looks like you get
books wow i got light bulbs i got books
yeah and here's the thing like i'm i'm
thankful that i have such a great family
and such a great support system people
would send me books but there's a lot of
people that didn't have books with these
people in there now for j6 are they can
people send them stuff yes you guys
could send them uh books they have to be
through a certain process like barnes
and noble through the usps system um and
certain books will get yeah you can send
them letters but they get the letters
here's the thing uh
it was
january and i was getting mail from
september
so it's a hit or miss sometimes it'll
take three weeks sometimes it'll take
four months thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time